what the hell are you doing in Ukraine
so it's a war zone it's cold as [__] you
know like what's going on in that
coconut of yours like what are you
thinking
well I live here I've been living here
in Ukraine uh in Kharkov which is in
East Ukraine I've been living here off
and on since 2016.
I I uh I had some business that I was
doing in London and that's when I
started doing uh the coach red pill
Channel back in 2017. yeah and um it was
really a hobby because I had a lot of
free time on my hands while I was in
London doing my uh my business Affairs
and the channel took off and so I just
continued it and um then in 2019 I had
another business deal that was going
down and so I I was sort of explaining
my time between Kharkov and Amsterdam
when I was in London it was sort of like
you know one week in one week in in
London and then the same thing in
Amsterdam and uh kovid uh the coveted
lockdown and caught me there in um
March of 2020 and I was was stuck in
Amsterdam really for most of 2020 and
then I rode my motorcycle back from
from Amsterdam to krakov
um in what December of 2020 and I've
been living here ever since and very
happily so until this little war
happened you know and uh exactly a year
ago today a year ago right now as I'm
speaking to you I had flown out to Kiev
on some business and some just
bureaucratic stuff I had to take care of
I went to Kiev uh on the 23rd of
February 2022
and at this time it's 6 p.m here as I'm
speaking to you I was having drinks with
some business acquaintances
um in my hotel the the premier Palace in
Kiev just off Chris Shattuck Avenue and
uh I I recall this all very vividly
because you know uh that evening rather
than go out to dinner or anything I just
decided to you know Dash over down the
street to the McDonald's there and and
get some Mickey D's and just chill out
in front of cable and I fell asleep
until like 5 30 in the morning when my
assistant here in karco gave me a call
and said the Russians are invading and
so for the first week of the invasion I
was in Kiev and um I'd wound down my uh
my coach red pill channel in late 2021
because I was just getting tired of it
you know and I was just winding down the
whole thing and um you know but I still
had the Channel with you know quarter of
a million 300 000 subs or whatever it
was and I started doing these impromptu
videos from kershatik Avenue which is
like the main drag or not the main drag
but the the principal Avenue
of of Kiev sort of like the Wilshire
Boulevard of of Kiev or or you know the
Madison Avenue Kip and uh I started
doing these impromptu videos talking
about the situation on the ground in the
middle of Kiev and uh all of a sudden
you know I'm this geopolitical
commentator and of course since this
conflict is ongoing I've continued
making videos because you know it
directly affects my life you know and so
yeah I was I was in Kiev from the 24th
until my birthday the night before my
birthday uh when I took the train back
to Kharkov and uh I I was here on the
first of March and I've been here since
then and uh I I arranged for the
evacuation of my family and they're out
of the country and for various reasons I
decided to stay because I didn't think
that this war would last this long
um I mean if somebody had told me back
in March of last year that I would you
we'd be here A year later talking about
this I would have been shocked and
what's emerged
um what's very interesting is that the
camp regime and the Russians had
actually reached a ceasefire agreement
in early April of last year
and it was the West the Washington you
know deep State crowd the state
department crowd
that uh put the kibosh on that they told
zlonski no uncertain terms that he
should not sign any kind of ceasefire or
or any kind of agreement with the
Russians and it's because of Washington
that this war has continued for a year
with literally hundreds of thousands of
deaths uh on the side of the zielinski
regime what's the um
what are the um
what's the uh death count right now on
both sides do you have any idea yeah the
casualty figures uh these are the last
reputable figures that are the most
conservative and the most like for sure
okay uh they come from two sources
um the the lowest casualty figures for
the Russian for the uh the Lindsay
regime rather but the Ukraine side they
have uh killed in action 157 000. uh
wounded in action likely about 150 of
that number so you're talking roughly
about 240 000 men who have been uh
wounded incapacitated
okay so between those two figures you're
talking total for 400 000 men are out of
commission between that 157 killed and
that 240 that are incapacitated
um on the Russian side uh these are
Western figures by the way or or figures
critical of the Russians uh the BBC puts
the number of confirmed dead
um Russian
uh LPR forces DPR forces Wagner and
chechens they put them at minimum 12 000
killed and perhaps maximum twenty
thousand the Israelis the Mossad puts it
at 18 850 as of January 22nd or
something like that
and so the Russians are destroying the
ukrainians yeah it's uh lopsided across
the board in terms of equipment lost in
terms of Slaughter yeah it's it's
lopsided as all get out yeah because I
mean the news here if you consume public
news media would would purport that um
the Russians are really getting a lot of
resistance uh goes zelinski
um you know they're probably going to
win blah blah blah but you're saying on
the ground there it's it's really just a
Slaughter
yeah the the figure it's roughly in
terms of men material across every
weapons class it's it's a lopsided
figure of between eight to one against
the zonski regime and uh as low as four
to one in so far as helicopters
specifically in so far as artillery
pieces I think it's something like 20 to
one and so I mean no it's it's just
incredibly lopsided because the
population of Ukraine well before the
war
um the official number was 45 million
okay
um but because of the people who have
left roughly 15 million people have left
a third of the population uh they've
left something like four million have
gone to Russia and 11 million have gone
to the West
and so you discount that you discount to
the 9 million people who are now in the
territories that Russia has annexed
that's about yeah like I said nine
million and so right now the population
of Ukraine the credible estimates from
multiple sources is a range between 19
million and 22 million yeah so they've
they've cut the population in half
and uh and this isn't over yet you know
would you call this a proxy war and what
do you think of it oh yeah that's of
course it's a proxy war between uh NATO
and Russia you know uh NATO the state
department specifically
um
Victoria Newland who is the under
Secretary of State for political Affairs
Anthony blinken who's supposed to be the
Secretary of State but there's really
Victoria Newland is number one
and Joe Biden himself and the National
Security advisor
um what's his name Jeff Sullivan what
they want is regime change in Russia and
they're using Ukraine and the sanctions
and throwing away the European economy
to create that regime change in Russia
and they failed they failed misery I
mean because in right now Putin in
Russia and this is according to polls by
anti-putin uh sectors put his approval
rating in somewhere between 70 and 80
percent okay so so I mean you know he
he's nothing's going on and also what's
what's happened is that see back in
2014-15 when Russia annexed Crimea the
Crimean peninsula
uh the United States put impose a whole
bunch of sanctions which really hurt the
Russian economy back then
and what's happened is that since then
the Russians have prepared for sanctions
war and they prepared very diligently
and in fact
they over prepared because what happened
was that the sanctions that came in 2022
which were a lot more severe because
they disconnected Russia from Swift they
uh abscond really with
um the Russian central banks Assets in
the west and and other measures that
they took but what happened was that
those sanctions had less of an effect on
the Russian economy than the sanctions
back in 2015. because yeah in uh March
April there was like you know the ruble
shot up you know the Moscow stock market
crashed but then it kind of like
recovered because everybody started
realizing hey you know this isn't
hurting that bad and the Russians also
discovered that they had all these
customers in India and China for their
uh energy resources and and their
exports and so losing the European
economy the Western economies in fact
didn't really hurt the Russian economy
and and more more importantly it opened
up new opportunities and new markets in
India and China and so now they are
selling more than before the war they
are doing better economically now than
before the war okay and even the IMF the
international monetary fund which is a
western uh organization even they admit
the fact that the Russian economy is
doing gangbusters and their inflation is
projected to be for 2023 something like
maybe four five percent something like
that
and and overall they're just this didn't
hurt the Russian economy at all it just
crippled the German economy and the
European economy overall and on top of
that you have of course of the United
States to carry out this terrorist
attack on the North stream pipeline
which condemned because I've been
because I've been confirmed by a good
source
Seymour Hersh is the who's the best
investigative uh journalist you can find
Seymour Hirsch has been around for five
decades
he broke the milai massacre in 1968. he
also broke the story of the Abu grave
um
um torture of prisoners by the Americans
in Iraq and the the clandestine bombing
of Cambodia a bunch of stories I mean
he's you know as as gold standard as you
can get in so far as investigative
journalism and a couple of weeks ago
three weeks ago now he released a a very
detailed piece as to who what where why
and so far as Nordstrom and the decision
was made in the fall of 2021 by Joe
Biden himself in coordination with
Victoria Newland and Jake Sullivan to
bomb the Nordstrom pipeline Jake
Sullivan was the point man for that
operation and um in in Seymour Hershey's
piece which has gotten zero play in the
mainstream media I mean nothing they
don't talk about it at all this guy has
won a Pulitzer Prize he published in the
New Yorker the New York Times I mean
this is as gold standard as you can get
and they have totally you know memory
hold it not even memory hold it just
ignored it like it has not happened
although the rest of the world has most
certainly paid attention to it and the
Americans indisputably bombed the north
stream Pipeline and this crippled the
German economy
and uh you know the German economy is
toast I mean they are [__] to to high
heaven right now their inflation food
inflation is at 20 percent
yeah and and sorry the north stream
pipeline was a gas supply line from
Russia to was it was it through Denmark
into Germany no it was under the Baltic
Sea from from Russia to Germany under
the Baltic Sea okay and it passed by
Denmark and what has emerged from from
uh Seymour Hershey's reporting is that
the Danes the swedes and the Norwegians
and the poles knew that this was coming
and in fact it was the Norwegians who
pulled the trigger who actually
detonated the bombs at the Americans
placed in June of 2022 during this big
Baltic Sea exercise that they did that's
when the American divers put in these uh
explosives you got to understand these
explosives they're not like little
package of C4 and they blow it up no
it's like a really complicated thing
because they have to dig up you know the
pipeline because it's covered and the
kind of uh explosives you're talking
about or you know a couple hundred
pounds per per charge and they had two
charges on each of four Pipelines and so
is a major operation logistically to
carry it out and it was apparently the
Norwegians who pulled the trigger on it
and
you know and Norway is part of NATO the
United States is part of NATO Germany is
part of NATO so Germany's own allies
[__] them over for money that's the
worst part because the Norwegians um uh
uh motivation was that they would be
able to sell their natural gas that they
have quite a bit of but more expensive
than Russian gas they'd be able to sell
their gas to Germany and the United
States also had that Financial
motivation to sell American liquefied
Natural Gas to the Germans quite apart
from the geopolitical aspects of it so
it's really I don't understand yeah I
don't I don't recall much outrage or
much coverage on this stock I mean
people are still outraged over over
pronouns or
pronouns and balloons yeah balloons and
wokeness or something is getting way
more media coverage and that's what
people get upset about
um I'm sure there's probably more people
that are still pissed off that others
haven't haven't gone and Jab themselves
you know to
comply you know with the new thing yeah
it's a clown world you know it's a cloud
we call this a clown world show right
yeah Dan's a complete [__] show at this
point no I mean like every day the kind
of [__] that's going on it's just
off the charts it's just the way off the
charts you know I mean every outrage
that you see every day you know and and
I mean this kind of thing I mean like
one of these incidents okay I mean 10 20
years ago would have been Front Page
News across the world but the American
Media is total propaganda the Canadian
media has total propaganda you're not
going to hear what's going on if you
follow the mainstream news sources yeah
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full-length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out